estos residentes decid me exigen
libertad pero las autoridades locales
los acusan de egoísmo el confinamiento
de la ciudad fue decretado a finales de
junio y debido al reciente aumento de
casos de kobe 19 se ha ampliado hasta
finales de septiembre
decenas de personas fueron detenidas
durante las manifestaciones del sábado
contra el encierro y cientos fueron
multadas por incumplir las órdenes de
salud pública a pesar de estas estrictas
medidas nuevas gales del sur cuya
capital es sídney registró el domingo
otro aumento récord de infecciones
informando de 830 nuevos casos y tres
muertes y sus los casos en este momento
no están subiendo exponencialmente
subieron bastante en los últimos días
pero sólo en los dos últimos días por
supuesto han sido más de 800 rasgos es
pérdida de salud desde el comienzo de la
pandemia australia ha hecho frente a los
brotes imponiendo estrictos
confinamientos medidas que sólo en los
dos últimos meses han costado a la
economía más 17.000 millones de dólares
australianos en declaraciones a la
televisión el domingo el primer ministro
scott morrison defendió su política
diciendo que los confinamientos serían
necesarios hasta que el 70% de la
población esté vacunada hasta ahora sólo
un 30% de los mayores de 16 años han
recibido las dos vacunas pero el viernes
se administró al mayor número de dosis
hasta hoy
y ayer fue otro día récord de vacunación
con más de 310.000 vacunas administradas
en toda australia
si se mantiene la actual tasa de
vacunación el 70% de los australianos
habrán sido completamente vacunados a
principios de noviembre